[Musique]
qui ici a peur de vieillir le et à main
vous êtes nombreux mais dans le
vieillissement il n'y a pas que la peur
il n'y a pas que l'horreur qui ici un
bon souvenir de son grand père ou de sa
grand-mère la main vous êtes encore plus
nombreux dans le vieillissement
il y à cette dualité cette ambiguïté on
en a une perception positive nos
grands-parents affectueux attentif leur
mémoire leur amour et puis cette
perception négative
la peur la peur de la décrépitude
la peur de la maladie
la peur de la mort et de fait lui
vieillissement s'accompagne de maladie
il ya une grande communauté de
chercheurs dont je fais partie qui
luttent et qui combat les maladies liées
au vieillissement et la recherche avance
la recherche avance rapidement dans le
début des années 90 on trouve le premier
gène capables d'augmenter la longévité
d'un animal un petit verre un hématome
d'un millimètre de long mais tout de
même un animal dans les années 2000 on
trouve un gène capables d'augmenter la
longévité d'une souris c'est un
mammifère beaucoup plus proche de nous
en 2009 c'est plus un gène mais une
molécule capable d'augmenter la
longévité de cette même souri et
aujourd'hui on est en train de chercher
des médicaments qui pourraient
éventuellement rentrer en essai clinique
pour traiter les maladies du
vieillissement chez l'homme
alors bien sûr c'est un progrès c'est
moins de souffrance moins de maladies
c'est moins de cancers moins de maladies
dégénératives moins de maladies
cardiovasculaires mais en parallèle de
cette course il y à un mouvement qui
s'appelle le transhumanisme peut-être en
avez vous déjà entendu parler l'abord de
la mort l'homme qui vivra milan
cette course là n'est pas tout à fait de
la même nature
bien sûr elle est basée sur l'élan et la
rapidité avec lesquelles des recherches
avancent mais la rhétorique
transhumanistes est assez violente
elle vous met sous le fait accompli
l'homme qui vivra milan est déjà né et
cette conviction
cette perception absolue est en fait
basée sur une peur ancien est bien
compréhensible
la peur de mourir alors où mettre le
curseur que croire et ne pas croire
pour répondre à cette question il faut
revenir un peu en arrière et se poser
des questions de base est la première
des questions c'est qu'est-ce que le
vieillissement la plupart d'entre nous
pensons au vieillissement comme au
processus d'usure comme un t-shirt suge
et se déchirent notre corps vieillit et
meurt
mais la biologie nous montre qu'en fait
ce n'est pas si simple
la biologie nous montre que le processus
du vieillissement n'est ni obligatoire
ni systématique
il existe des organismes comme l'hydre
qui ne vieillissent pas l'hydre est un
petit être aquatique qui réellement
semble ne pas vieillir
alors ça peut paraître une anecdote mais
ça nous enseigne quelque chose
d'important ça nous enseigne que le
vieillissement n'est pas synonyme du
vivant en fait le vivant c'est
précisément la capacité de propager la
vie d'une génération à une autre est de
faire en sorte que ce fils de la ville
jamais ne s'interrompent évidemment les
transhumanistes se saisissent de cette
observation et vous dise si l'hydre peut
le faire pourquoi pas nous cette
observation vous dis aussi que le
vieillissement
ce n'est pas exactement comme mesure
alors pourquoi vieillissons nous ça peut
paraître une question triviale mais elle
ne l'est pas tant que ça puisque l'hydre
vieilli ne vieillit pas et nous si
il est très difficile de répondre avec
certitude à cette question mais on peut
commencer à réfléchir sur certains
éléments
il existe vis-à-vis de la capacité à
propager la vie plusieurs stratégies et
quand je parle de stratégie je parle de
choix évolutif qui ont été faits il ya
des millions d'années dans le cadre du
vieillissement
il existe la stratégie de l'hydre dont
la plupart des cellules sont capables de
se régénérer et de se rajeunir et il
existe notre stratégie et nous avons
concentré notre capacité de régénération
et de rajeunissement dans un tout petit
nombre de cellules
ces cellules ce sont les cellules de la
reproduction
on les appelle des cellules germinales à
chaque fois qu'on se reproduit nous nous
rajeunissons à chaque fois que nous
faisons un bébé nos cellules germinales
produisent des cellules rajeunie qui
elles mêmes vont produire un bébé qui du
coup naîtra à l'âge 0 ça peut paraître
évident mais c'est pas si simple que ça
comment deux être mature alger sont
capables de produire un être neuf c'est
justement ça qui est différent si le
vivant de l'inerte alors
notre immortalité elle réside en fait
dans nos enfants alors pourquoi avoir
choisi choisi cette stratégie plutôt
qu'une autre
encore une fois il est très difficile de
répondre avec fermeté à une question
comme celle ci mais ce qu'on remarque
c'est que très souvent les organismes
qui vieillissent sont souvent plus
complexes nous avons fait le choix de
concentrer notre capacité ancestrale de
transmettre la vie dans un tout petit
nombre de cellules et du coup nous avons
pu développer beaucoup d'autres cellules
qui sont capables de remplir beaucoup
d'autres fonctions
ces cellules ce sont les cellules
somatiques toutes cellules qui n'est pas
germinal est une cellule somatique et
ces cellules sont en charge de remplir
toutes les fonctions qui ne sont pas
celles de la reproduction et le détail
et la spécificité des fonctions que ces
cellules sont capables de remplir et
fascinant une cellule de muscles peut se
contracter une cellule nerveuse peut
produire un courant électrique qui
traverse notre corps et qui synchronise
son action grâce aux cellules somatiques
nous pouvons voir nous pouvons courir
nous pouvons danser nous pouvons penser
nous pouvons aimer
alors pensons aimons les cellules
somatiques sont extrêmement diversifiée
et on voit bien qu'il existe un
antagonisme entre la capacité de
réaliser ces tâches très spécialisées et
la capacité de se régénérer
ces cellules fascinante ont développé
des capacités extraordinaires mais elles
ont perdu leur capacité originale de
rajeunissement
comme ces cellules constituent la
principale partie de notre être et
qu'elle vieillisse nous vieillissons
aussi ces cellules donne de la couleur à
notre vie est en fait ces cellules qui
donne à nos grands parents ces
caractéristiques que nous aimons leur
mémoire leur amour leur regard on voit
donc bien que la première intuition que
le vieillissement n'est pas forcément
quelque chose de négatif est véridique
il ya du positif dans le vieillissement
et dia du positif dans sa raison d'être
biologique
alors que faire
devant le vis bien sûr il faut continuer
à chercher
il faut continuer à comprendre et je
m'inscris dans ce mouvement de recherche
qui constitue à comprendre les voies
métaboliques qui nous permettront de
guérir les maladies du vieillissement
comme nous avons guérit les maladies
infectieuses et nous y arriverons
l'autre proposition la proposition
transhumanistes est une proposition
radicalement différente
elle vous propose de passer à
l'immortalité est ce que cela est
possible
difficile de répondre parviendrons nous
à être immortel sans perdre nos
fonctions somatiques pas si évident que
ça est ce souhaitable
encore moins évident en tout cas on
comprend mieux maintenant que
contrairement à ce que la rhétorique
transhumanistes dit il ne sera pas si
simple de se rendre immortel parce qu'il
s'agira de changer notre architecture
entière de revenir sur des choix
évolutif qui ont en effet été fait il ya
des millions d'années alors que faire
devant le vieillissement pensons
cherchons aimons merci
[Applaudissements]